the part that I played Sarah link and
the sister of Abe Lincoln who is there
at his birth and so that was an amazing
opportunity to play that part and then
my older sister played the same part of
Sarah Lincoln later on in the film as
Sarah Lincoln grew but I really can't
remember a great deal I do remember I
always loved the stills I had kept a
number of this still so the family had
kept for me and when I always looked at
those I've always through the years I
thought my goodness that was really a
wonderful experience to vet in that film
and as I say it was pretty little to
remember a lot about it but I do
remember it I remember that eating the
the soup or whatever it was that we had
in front of the fire and I remember that
scene very well and I can remember that
the actor that is telling me a story so
it was um it was a quite quite an event
for a youngster well as I say the whole
family worked in pictures and they were
all working and the neighbors knew us
well and and kind of looked out for me
and I was you know playing and I was
fine and everything and the phone rang
and it was a call for me to go to work
and I do remember what I mostly remember
about it is that I was pleased that I
got a job and I can remember sitting on
the steps of our house with my little
makeup case waiting for the studio to
send a car to pick me up and they did
and obviously they must have been in
touch with my mother and father some way
because no one seems to have thought
much about it but I can remember I was
very proud that you know I was getting
another opportunity to display my acting
talents I'll tell you one of the things
that is chuckle that I remember when
there was one director and I
bill Schneider that was his name he was
big wonderful director was married to a
big star Marion Nixon I remember you all
these things now and we had a little
deal between the two of us when he would
always cry on cue
I mean it's my job I could cry you want
me to cry cry
and so when he wanted me to cry he would
say to me I'm gonna cut off your curls I
was gone I mean that's all he needed and
that was always that was always my cue
you want him to tears I've got to cut
off your curls and they're right go
you